hey guys my name is Jeff I'm Dan and
look at this afternoon we've got here in
Sydney it is lovely and a perfect time
on Friday to let you know about the
biggest things that have been going on
in gaming this week be sure to say
subscribe see notice any of the news but
for now he's the top stories
so oldest tree was a pretty massive hit
at e3 this year great things for the
camera but uh Mario creator Shigeru
Miyamoto was actually a little worried
that people weren't gonna be keen on it
was that well it was because he was
worried that people gonna be weirded out
by the height of Mario buses the height
of the regular civilians of noon from
you dog city that's such a week if
they're a little bit taller than him
right and he was also worried that
people were gonna be like why are all
these citizens like not caring that just
like a little Mario bro it's like
jumping around and throwing his hat at
things and jumping on everything I mean
I can see that but thankfully he like
came to his senses right because he
thought he realized Pauline exists
that's right so he was just like let's
roll with it and they have and then we
have Odyssey yeah and it's gonna be out
on October 27th so it's really not that
far away
then what do you think is Bioware the
most successful game that they at launch
um probably know it's Dragon Age
Inquisition a game I love making another
one all right well I don't know if it's
another Inquisition but Michael a load
the creative director of the entire
Dragon Age series has been like hey I'm
still here and I'm not been fired yet
and he said something's happening
something's happening with Dragon Age
was his direct play what if it's all
been thrown out no it's not been thrown
out because they're doing a lot of
hiring right now sir um it looks like
things are really getting underway for
the next dragon age I know Inquisition
with a little device if not everybody
liked it personally hide it I didn't
like it look at this Tobuscus
really glad to see that they're working
on a new one and I think by ways
less than slightly so I'm really
optimistic about what the way the series
is right now
somehow I haven't played pretty boy
Adventure Club 2016 yeah Wow 5:15 that's
what it's at that was that's the second
tunnel they were but I found out that
you can now drive the car anyway which
makes what makes me want to play it even
more yeah the 1.12 updates just toggle
the rails off the roads you used to have
to drive down the road and now you don't
have to you just like drive your car out
in the wilderness wherever you want and
you cause now a monster truck when you
want to drive it out there
sounds bananas there's also new are
songs on the radio yeah bunch of bug
fixes and it was all to prepare it for
the episode prompter DLC which is out
now hey then oh well they're bringing
out another one well sort of they bring
it out a mini version of it yeah just
like the NES classic games and they
sound really good there do anyone games
in fact but don't become country Secret
of Mana yep
Oh mana depending on what part of the
globe you're from and also Star Fox to
the unreleased sequel to Star Fox which
yeah which is huge actually so the
developer may be engineering on that
games like I'm so excited to see it's
coming out I bet you are also it's gonna
be available in greater numbers this
time then compared to the NES classic
which is fantastic yes and also more
fantastic news the chords are gonna be
longer on the controllers right and
they're gonna be talking this time
that's pretty cool so it's available
from September until the end of the year
that's when it's gonna be shipping so
you can pre-order I pre-order now just
cross those things like right now
there's probably some places that are
still selling nice but uh you know
what's already starting to go at some
retailers so if you really want to get
your hands on this one you probably want
to do that quietly okay 5.5 million
people own grunt it's crazy it's crazy
but three hundred three hundred and
thirty thousand I believe have asked for
refunds which is baffling okay that
seems like a lot and it also translates
to they've lost four point three million
dollars in having to refund my go copies
of the game but at the same time you
know when you consider the number
have it and the fact that the steam
refund system probably encouraged people
to try out and buy game saying otherwise
may not have done before those may not
have been sure things sales in the first
place so I don't think it's a terrible
thing but it has been really interesting
that you know creator Garry Newman has
decided to release these statistics
totally and I also think it's something
that you're right people who don't know
what has it come across the plated for
an hour and a half like Oh not
understanding it's an early access game
like this is a broken mess I don't wanna
play this me I just want to run around
without any pants on first business self
yeah I mean he also revealed that the
listed reasons for why people wanted
refunds were most commonly that it was
not fun or bad performance but I feel
like that's gotta be most of the time
right I mean you don't really mistakenly
bar things it's probably because it
turns out to not be your thing
interesting figures those that's guess
what news for this week and as always
I've been just McDonald I've not been I
don't know one would wonder baby will
catch us again next week and we'll be
back on Monday and if you want to get
some news over the weekend you can grab
the games but now have to get the top
ten news stories of the day to live and
write to your phone also
happy Independence Day for next week
that's right have a great long weekend
if you're getting a long weekend oh we
don't have one so we'll be back giving
you news on Monday you know what else is
an interesting figure dance straight
down like a french fry
[Laughter]